bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans l'émission
à 6 on parler sport le talk est consacré
comme vous le savez à l'actualité
sportive dans le département vous
connaissez le problème de l'émission il
y aura des coups de gueule des débats et
des duels cinq chroniqueurs sont en
plateau aujourd'hui ils sont plus
remontés que jamais avec l'euro qui se
déroule en ce moment en france
présentation en musique on commence à
droite si on devait le comparer un pays
de 7 euros
on pourrait le comparer à la croatie
créatif au milieu avec une attaque
efficace il vient de décrocher le titre
de champion de france master en cyclisme
sur piste
bonjour jan bonjour ni elle est bien
très bien une réaction par rapport à vos
titres de champion de france
noir et un particulier ou à doubler ou l
vitesse par des visites vitesse
individuelle et vitesse par équipes plus
une médaille d'argent sur 750 mètres
donc ce week-end très satisfaisant
encourageant pour aller préparer les
championnats du monde qui seront
l'objectif principal de la saison
non pour vous cette tranquille ça s'est
très très bien passé
parfait on passe à notre deuxième
chroniqueur musique on peut le comparer
à l'équipe d'italie solide en défense
compacte incisifs ils n'hésitent pas à
partir en compte pour battre ses
adversaires pendant les duels notre
spécialiste
handball alexandre taillefer est avec
nous l'italie a bien admis que je vois
l'italie avait au moins en 2009 donc ça
me correspond je pense quand même un
petit peu le bout fin de cette émission
de c'est ma vocation
le charismatique bouffonne repasse à
droite musique comme la france y joue à
domicile dans cette émission il adore
faire le spectacle en marquant des buts
en lucarne dans les arrêts de jeu comme
dimitri payet
mustapha larbaoui le président du club
de football de trappes est avec nous
aujourd'hui vous allez bien vous servir
de votre chiot merci vous êtes prêts
pour savoir tony démission bas pour
produire du spectacle et des pailles et
puisque prix
c'est noté 1re passe à gauche musique on
peut le comparer à l'équipe d'espagne il
aime faire tourner la balle a accéléré
dans les derniers mètres pour créer des
décalages il aime avoir la possession du
ballon aux dernières émissions il est le
temps de parole de à temps de parole de
55% guillaume nero 9 du risque net à
l'espagnol de cette équipe possession
une possession on est d'accord là dessus
et tu es sûr d'en vous étudiez vos stats
55%
bon pas mal moustapha n'a pas de faire
attention
on termine peut-être par l'air par la
suppose surprise de ce talk musique
outsider avant le début de cette
émission il a su s'imposer à chaque
numéro avec ses connaissances au sport
local et sa force de caractère dans les
duels homériques face à moustapha al
harbaoui notre stand et vas-y la rigole
il est avec nous bonjour vasile bonjour
michael allait bien très bien ça va
motivé comme jamais islandais vous êtes
les stands et de sages équipe on va
prendre on va prendre présentation avant
de passer aux différents thèmes
d'émissions je vous propose un extrait
le psg s'est essayé au football
américain
et le colombus sourire comme hello voilà
le mot
alors je ne sais pas si vous avez fait
attention alexandra cet extrait les
joueurs du psg utilise l'équipement des
templiers d'elancourt
mais quand le qui vive et mais sinon je
trouve maintenant je comprends mieux
pourquoi ils passent ils peuvent aller
mission du coup ça va
une réaction par amara cet extrait
aucune si ce n'est que le casque est pas
tout à fait paramétrer pour le pôle type
de sport mais sinon tout va bien je
aucun commentaire c'est une bonne pub
pour les templiers ou par gamme bas même
nous on n'avait pas vu alors comment
dire enfin comment dire ça peut être une
bonne pub peut-être pour les
spécialistes mais voilà ça va encore
rester sur un pur dans le microcosme du
football américain qui va se rendre
compte que ben le psg à utiliser leurs
dents matériel mais les sinon c'est un
équipement d'une équipe locale banon
avec la religion
je veux pas vers elle investirait autant
justement avant et puis et puis ça fait
peut-être qu'il ya certains joueurs des
templiers qu'on peut rencontrer ces
grands sportifs parce que en tout avant
avant d'être un footballeur
professionnel on est quand même aussi
avant un gros un gros est un grand
sportif
donc voilà habillé coup et peut être un
petit billet pour le cédant on sait que
14 ont envie de s'investir beaucoup aux
états unis ce que les dans le 4e tour
l'américaine salle p g va tous les ans
aux états unis là depuis un certain
temps et je pense que ça s'inscrit là
dessus où ils ont pris l'équipe qui à
côté d'un agent parisienne la meilleure
et puis et puis voilà pour pour un peu
sponsorisés de ce port est entre
guillemets et puis et puis qui sait
peut-être que ça se voit aux états unis
en disant voilà nous on représente le
sport américain en france en faisant un
petit coup de pub à culte chez nous quoi
les économistes peut-être pour cristiano
ronaldo
on va passer maintenant au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
justement parler des 30 ans du club de
football américain des templiers
d'elancourt nous parlerons également
handball avec plaisir qu'ils remportent
la coupe des yvelines mais tout de suite
coup de projecteur sur l'euro 2016
l'euro 2016 a débuté le 10 juin en
france je vous le rappelle trois équipes
avaient choisi pour camp de base les
yvelines l'équipe de france est à
clairefontaine la réussite et à
croissy-sur-seine et l'équipe d'irlande
est à versailles au stade mont boron est
également en retrait en palace de
versailles nous allons faire un bilan de
ces trois équipes à l'issue de ces
phases de groupes qui vous a le plus
déçu ne répondait pas tout de suite on
va regarder les groupes on commence tout
de suite par le groupe de l'équipe de
france l'équipe coachée par didier
deschamps termine première de son groupe
avec 7 points devant la suisse et
l'albanie la roumanie termine elle à la
dernière place du groupe avec un petit
point
on regarde maintenant le groupe de
l'irlande qui termine troisième du
groupe de la mort les boys in green sont
qualifiés pour les 8e de finale avec la
nouvelle règle des 3 meilleurs de chaque
groupe testé pour la première fois cette
année par l'uefa en termine par la
russie l'équipe russe a été l'une des
déceptions de cet euro surnommée la
sbornaja il termine à la dernière place
du classement du groupe b avec un match
nul et deux défaites dans la compétition
le groupe a été dominé à la surprise
générale par le pays de galles qui vous
a le plus déçu
messieurs tissu la france
poutine on commence par william qui vous
a le plus déçu alors la france parce
qu'on avait tout le monde avait peur
d'eux
de l'assise défensive de cette charnière
centrale qui n'existait pas avant l'euro
et on s'aperçoit que adil rami a fait
largement le boulot que plus de
différences ivement ça se passe de mieux
en mieux plus les matchs avancent par
contre notre notre ligne d'attaqué qui a
flambé pendant beaucoup de matchs
préparatoires
ben elle est un peu nu est donc voilà
pour moi les trois équipes celles qu'il
est plus déçu parce que c'est celle que
j'attendais c'est la france donc du coup
voilà de l'équipe il attendait c'était
la france donc du coup je suis pas
d'accord parce que enfin clos sécurité
des français le plus déçu d'accord mais
sur l'analyse parce que il rencontré
quand même la roumanie et l'albanie qui
défend des as 10 dans leur camp donc
c'est quand même très compliqué de
marquer des buts à la roumanie leur
marque et de en à ma surprise en tant
que c'est que deux en deux ans c'était
plutôt une bonne performance
l'albanie finalement il en marque de
aussi et finalement bizarrement c'est le
match le plus ouvert où il n'y a pas eu
de but mais il n'y avait pas payet il
manquait quelques joueurs donc on peut
aussi confie l'enjeu était là on sait
que le match nul suffisait pour être
premier donc les joueurs étaient pas
aussi motivé à mon avis pour s'arracher
les matchs souviens je suis sûr à
contrario la défense était pas très
compliqué puisque justement il n'y avait
pas la tacc donc je pense que je suis
bien mentalement il y aura des contres
alors contre
pas la roumanie mais après l'albanie
avoir mis sur facebook
si les albanais continue de reculer vous
rentrer avec lui donc c'est vrai que
c'est un petit peu ce que j'avais aussi
vu pendant le match guillaume non par
bonne équipe qui vous a le plus déçu
comptablement la russie quoi fin il n'y
a pas de vous êtes vraiment l'aspect
comptable il se révèle ici entre eux et
ils rentrent et et justice sur terre
donc voila moi je alors moi juste par
rapport à la russie je pense que les
événements qui se sont passés extra
sportifs ont certainement
u10 légalisme dans les rues de marseille
par exemple tout à fait ça moi je pense
à autre chose sinon ça a joué sur la
tête des joueurs
je pense que je pense que c'est pour ça
que je suis là parce que le match le
match nul contre l'angleterre était on
va dire prévisible mais
mais voilà ce qui sait ce qui s'est
passé derrière ça a pu et surtout que
tout le monde s'est rendu compte que
c'était à la base pas les anglais qui
avaient qui avait mis le feu aux poudres
mais vraiment bien sûr dans les rues ce
jeu parce que vous savez mais un ca de
la russie dernière coupe du monde s'est
pas qualifié et dernier euro s'est pas
qualifié donc nous en laissons son âme
et millésimes les organisera la coupe du
monde 2018 ça c'est très inquiétant
j'avance jusque on rêve de russie de
l'époque il ya très longtemps qui gagner
mais au jour d'aujourd'hui et je crois
je crois que tous les athlètes russes
ont été aussi sont au milieu d'un gros
scandale ils vont parler ses formes
athlètes j'ai bien dit athlètes les
adler effectivement on doit parler de
fausses d'appât on n'avait pas encore
parlé
non j'ai pas parlé sur le plan technique
ya tellement de choses à dire et son
contraire
il ya des spécialistes pour ça et je les
entends sur les spécialistes sont les
plateaux d'ailleurs on a un gars on en a
on en a autour de nous des spécialistes
qui ont séparé à ce sujet non plus par
les caissons sont pas français damien
sont pas forcément d'accord
techniquement avant voire même après et
donc je suis pas trop sur le sur la
technique moi si évident qu'il y avait
deux déceptions à donner sur l'euro en
général
hormis les équipes et les on va dire le
sport en particulier c'est c'est d'abord
c'est tout ce qu'on a pu dire sur
l'organisation sur les fans zone il faut
pour faire des femmes zone la sécurité
doit primer faille et toute une paranoïa
légitime mais attention on est bien
d'accord
une paranoïa légitime on ne pensait on
n'a parlé que de ça on a eu beaucoup de
mal à démarrer
la fête donc moi ma déception c'était
plus par rapport aux gens qui ont pu
prédire des choses donc pour le coup en
creux
ça veut dire un grand coup de chapeau
tout ce qu'on fait cette organisation
qui s'est révélée est une organisation
exceptionnelle
je rappelle qu'il ya 51 matches au total
au total à 36,6 m ou bien je me suis je
me trompe pas parmi 36 de qualif il ya
eu quelques matchs qui ont posé des
problèmes
sauf que ces matches là était déjà
prévisible puisque c'est des matches
dits sensibles
donc globalement c'est de la déception
va à tous ceux qui ont prédit que ça se
passerait mal qui mettait un terme trop
tôt aux liga le russe par exemple pour
le coup il joue en liga nisme rooney
toujours en creux un grand bravo aux
organisateurs
et puis à tous les matchs vraiment j'en
ai vu deux au stade de france j'ai vu la
france bien sûr et la roumanie et j'ai
vu également souhait de république
d'irlande
mais au niveau du contenu vous avez vu
l'équipe de france contre lorient 1re
maintenant pour revenir sur la télé vous
ont déçu pour de nobles pour donner un
point de vue technique
moi je comprends pas qu'on soit déçu moi
j'avais écrit d'ailleurs cette antenne
c'est m c'était mon jeu de mots mais
elle est restée vous avez raison pour
roumanie albanie suisse ouais moi je
considérais visiter dans un groupe où il
n'y a rien à dire rien à signaler
prochain tient que le résultat donc j'ai
pensé qu'ils gagneraient qui serait
premier dans groupe s'est fait il n'y a
rien à signaler mais en même temps c'est
une compétition
elle est longue il faut pas sympa
s'acharner constamment sur le fait de
ces pas un spectacle seulement certes on
s'attend à on veut des buts on veut du
spectacle on en a eu en l'occurrence
avec payet par exemple mais ce n'est pas
le but
donc il ya la qualif d'abord être
premier même si les deux premiers des
fois c'est pas forcément la meilleure
place on va le voir en pet est tout à
l'heure mais globalement c'est un
championnat il est long ici encore
acceptable on disait qu'il n'est pas
petite équipe qu'il fallait pas penser
qu'il y avait des petits clubs on pense
à l'islande par exemple qui m'ont fait
une impression colossal
et puis et puis des gens qui reviennent
dans la compétition pour moi dans mon
esprit c'est la croatie
on a vu l'islande faire des merveilles
ne sait jamais que 350 350 mille
habitants donc la maison qui peuvent
constituer leur équipe et c'est donc moi
je ne suis pas déçu de la france
ils sont à leur rang et y gère voilà ça
se gère aussi une compétition c'est
comme ça que l'encens basile qui vous a
le plus déçu je suis assez d'accord avec
l'analyse de mustapha pour moi la vraie
compétition là commence à partir des
huitièmes de finale parce que c'est la
plus sûre voire même si on peut dire ça
comme ça au budget ouais on peut dire ça
surtout avec le nouveau système
d'échangé l'éducation et qui permet à
des équipes qui sont troisièmes de leur
poule d'accéder au tour suivant
donc oui après parmi eux la déception
sur entre l'irlande la france et la
russie s'est évidemment les russes ça
fait plusieurs années qu'on dit que le
championnat russe est de plus en plus
compétitif on voit on voit des clubs
russes qui vont de plus en plus loin en
coupe d'europe ça serait que des
champions europa league et finalement au
niveau international sur l'essai au
niveau de la sélection
il n'y a pas de progrès depuis des
années ce n'est pas le même financement
c'est ça que je voulais mais jamais les
joueurs les joueurs sont les mêmes des
joueurs de qualité dedans mais
maintenant tu l'as dans toutes les
équipes toutes les équipes comme vous on
écoute les quand on écoute les matches
vous avez des gars qui jouent pas mais
juste les grands championnats
après oui dans la région des cayes sud
bien l'esprit l'état d'esprit là le pas
historique qui va jouer quoi finalement
cela suffise à roubaix qui dans les
grands clubs ou quoi c'est vraiment d
envie de réussir ensemble un parcours et
d'aller loin dans mes classes juste un
petit bémol sur le sol us f1 n'est pas
du tout sûr la france sur le choix
d'avoir mis les 24 équipes parce qu'on
se rend compte que finalement les
équipes pouvaient s'arranger dis pas
qu'elles l'ont fait mais pouvait
s'arranger exemple francs suisses 1
match nul et qualifier les deux puis il
ya eu plein de matches comme ça et je
trouve ça triste pour le spectateur la
prof 0 0 était enfin des scores
abominable et puis en plus c'est quand
même litigieux quand on est l'équipe qui
s'est fait avoir de l'autre côté même si
je ne dis pas que francs suisses ou
d'autres matches on est à ranger en
rebeix c'est de gagner mais ne de façon
inconsciente les jours ils savent que le
match ne savait qualifie donc quelque
part voilà je pense que c'est un bémol
je pense que c'est pas judy
et dire que soit on fait 16 soit en fait
32 voilà mes 24 pour moi c'est pas un
bon chiffre parce que ça met des
troisième et donc ça mais tous acteurs
il me faisait rire qu'on invite à être
honteux ça veut dire qu'on a mis bout à
bout on va revenir sur le terrain
l'irlande
on a beaucoup parlé de la russie on a
comparé la france l'irlande finalement
qui s'extrait du groupe de la mort g
faisant penser à versailles mm avec
voilà avec qu'ils ont trouvé les bon bar
à les bouder supporter un truc de
montbard pour faire la fête et tout l
équipe de l des relents de celle ayant
trait à mouvoir fait la fête ya pas de
problème ils sont basés sur la l'esprit
enfin valait 1 to et festif c'est par
elle même et festif il parle voilà ils
sont dans la liste dont ils sont dans
leur foutent quoi enfin dans leur
foutent un peu un peu non moi je vis un
moment ils ont profité du fait que avec
ses 24 équipes y rencontrer l'italie qui
était sûr de finir premier et du coup on
gagne 1 0
c'est ici avait pas ça il serait pas je
suis pas d'accord avec vraiment avec son
analyse déjà sur l'équipe de france
aussi sur les derniers matches comme ça
on dit souvent ça m'a fait coiffer les
mecs et des mecs qui jouent pas trop
joue et c'est michael quand on a intérêt
à bien jouer parce qu'ils peuvent gagner
une place derrière pour y aller l'équipe
bis
ouais mais ils ont quand même intérêt à
grégory coupet
mais francky qui veut dire que jamais
pour moi ces mecs là quand même ils sont
sur le terrain ils sont quand même
histoire comme la sélection nationale
comme ils ont comme l intérêt à jouer à
fond pour aller gagner une place pour
les phases finales quotidien blessés si
un carton ce cas machin là mais fou qui
s'y filent quoi donc je suis pas vous
mais moi je les suis
nos versaillais en l'occurrence pour
faire les arranger le versaillais qui
font la promotion du trianon et la ville
de versailles pour les avoir vus au
stade de france contre la suède et je
serai à geoffroy guichard samedi
et c'est vrai que pour parler on entend
les duos reaganisme de chaleur à
linverse c'est un super public
on l'a dit donc voir un vieux
mais voilà je vous constatez je vous
l'avais les habits bio au stade de
france 2 françoise astruc comment ces
irlandais franchement c'est pas un match
qui m'a qui m'a marqué personnellement
je soutiens ces deux équipes qui est
quasiment s'anesthésier c'était un
masque sur la semaine mais un partout
c'est pas un match qui fondamentalement
avait fait de révéler l'une ou l'autre
rien de particulier moi c'est plus la
volonté des joueurs l'engagement et puis
l'état d'esprit avec un très bon joueur
que pour le 15 2
on va passer au prochain thème les faces
de les phases de groupes sont terminés
et on va passer m'attends donc aux
huitièmes de finale la france affrontera
l'irlande dans un derby évinois
sulfureux 40 minutes séparent seulement
les camps de base de versailles de
clairefontaine le match se disputera ce
dimanche 26 juin à 15 heures à lyon qui
est favori de cette rencontre vous voter
vert pour l'irlande rouge pour la france
hier pour la l'irlande forcément et
rouge pour la france à rouge pour la
france on va faire un petit duel entre
vous alexandre et basile a les bases ils
vont commencer oui j'ai mis du verre
parce que quand j'étais allé voir
l'entraînement ouvert au public les
irlandais la première chose que disaient
les spectateurs s'étaient rendez-vous en
valais on va aller en phase finale et on
veut rencontrer les français
on a une revanche à prendre sur ce
fameux match des éliminatoires et
apprennent à les diffuser à lorient
tingwick et les les supporters irlandais
n'attendent que ça de retrouver les
français et je pense qu'en vie va être
décuplée les joueurs eux aussi et je
pense que c'est un match
tout ça va être du 50-50 et que la
france a à la france si vous voulez dire
un accord tant 40 la france peut perdre
beaucoup sur ce match la pression
la présidence n'a pas énormément casser
la pression sera énormément sur les
éloges des français avec ces entités
beaucoup parce que l'image de son
entraîneur qui est un casseur
monumentale est encore dit et redit
contre du tamis jeu j'ai peur je crains
qu un des joueurs soit blessés
à l'issue de ce match je pense que la
france gagnera pas ce que je joue chez
elle
je pense que l'arbitrage sera légèrement
favorable à la france comme on a pu le
voir globalement sur la compétition et
que ça se joue sur des détails et que et
que par contre je pense ça va être très
dur probablement des prolongations fait
un match très dur convocation peut-être
un blessé pour la france j'espère
j'espère pas mais voilà je pense avait
pas être un beau match à voir et qu'on
va on va en laisser beaucoup beaucoup
d'énergie un peu à l'image du paraguay à
la coupe du monde 98 un match où vous
laisser beaucoup d'énergie mais ça
n'empêche pas que mes laurent blanc hier
les avait qualifiées en location à
brouillard
là on parle de maths qui vont être très
durs qui vont être très non et on pas
sur une deuxième phase faut pas oublier
une chose c'est que les français ont
joué dimanche dernier son office que les
irlandais jouent ou ont joué hier soir
et que le match et dans deux jours et
trois jours donc la récup n'est pas du
tout la même pour les irlandais ou pour
les français il n'y aura pas un manque
de rythme justement non non non mais
lloris notation non plus on sait très
bien que
que griezmann a besoin de repos en ce
moment plutôt que plutôt d'enchaîner les
d'enchaîner les matches et de faire des
matchs ou non c'est très bien payet
payet par ailleurs fatigué comme il est
dans l'agglo mais donc voila moi je
pense que là il ya quand même un gros
gros avantage pour pour l'équipe de
france à ce niveau là de rencontrer une
équipe qui a joué vraiment beaucoup plus
proche et qui en plus à un jeu qui est
très physique et donc qui arrive de les
payer et voilà quelques aventuriers
kamwa tournée qui risquent de payer sur
une sur une fin de match paul blick les
françaises championnes du monde de la
89e minute
vous serez prêt à parier votre vélo
l'ancien le nouveau nom vient aussi
aller non moi je pense que moi j'ai voté
vert donc moi je pense qu'il ya landes
peut faire un truc et soutenu paul
persiste et je signe notamment
voilà notamment pour l'histoire de leur
revanche de la main de thierry henry et
ce public extraordinaire qui va les
booster comme comme c'est pas permis
quoi parce que j'étais comme un doublé
public français justement on va regarder
un extrait des supporters la vidéo
amateur a été tourné dans les volumes
baril
et le
et
et yann dessin pas cette image oui oui
mais ils ont fait d'accord aussi un
champ pour féliciter nos policiers
aujourd'hui hier je sais plus j'y vois
là et draguer les filles comme comme les
rendait un peu plus ses petits jeux
subtils 5 millions de francs plus de
bruit que 45 française nouvelle parade
le voit parler les bleus le public va
jouer et lamar son rôle dans cette
rencontre
moi j'arrive pas à croire qu'on a ce
douzième dont on parle tout le temps
dans des compétitions comme ça
logiquement les français choisissent et
jaloux et et pour les avoir vus en
déshérence mar mitr le visionnement
l'occurrence ça sera éventuellement leur
habitat mais on parlait du public jeune
et sympa cool quand une fois pour les
avoir vus aux alentours du stade dans le
stade
c'est vrai qu'on a ce public on décrit
qu'on met maintenant et de cette qualité
de là à ce que ça fasse la différence
pour revenir sur la france la france
organise la coupe du monde elle gagne
elle organise la coupe d'europe
elles gagnent elle organise la coupe
d'europe encore une fois elle va gagner
simplement peut-être qu'il ya aussi il
ya aussi qu'on peut volume en
l'occurrence prend maintenant réparé la
stratégie fonctionne parce que j'entends
beaucoup parler de la déception qu'on
pourra voir l'équipe de france comme on
l'avait à une certaine époque qu'ils ont
gagné la coupe du monde et en même temps
on a peut-être que c'est la stratégie où
on flanche rime pas on fait nos matches
tranquillement et c'est peut-être là ça
va sortir non pas la surprise stratégie
on termine ce thème par les pronostics
on va commencer par bouyala vous pouvez
dire oralement pour les premières il
tracera le pronostic du match 2 0 2 0 2
1 pour les huitièmes donc pour les
huitièmes en moi je pronostique un zéro
parce qu'un but civil 0 en prolongation
nous
alexandre par ailleurs neuvième et avant
de vous faire des amis
après cette large page football et euro
2016 sont pas sots handball et à la
belle épopée de l'équipe senior de
plaisir
la logique a été respectée en finale de
la coupe des yvelines seniors au gymnase
des lavandières à saint germain en laye
le ce dimanche 19 juin les joueurs de
plaisir qui évolue en prénationale ont
battu montigny-le-bretonneux une équipe
de division honneur régionale le score
est sans appel 39 à 26 on écoute les
réactions début de match un peu
compliqué défensivement on n'était pas
présent mais qu'on a on a plus défendre
un peu plus fort sur l'homme on a n'a
plus joué les montées de balle et contre
attaque
je ne vais pas me faire l'écart en début
de deuxième mais à un moment on a
défendu un publiphone n'a pu monter les
ballons
celles visées
le long du match les voiliers qui mais
c'est un peu d'intensité nous on restait
sans même tempo c'était important était
plus fort sur le plan physique
à la sorte par des gabarits ce plan
aussi sur plan français ou niveau des
courses
mes joueurs étaient fatigués que les
heures de plaisir le macho
ça va être ça allait être difficile mais
une très bonne chose de la part de
deux collectifs saignant de montigny
loïc une victoire importante pour les
plaisirs aux allées jaune et noir ont
raté la montée pour la deuxième année
consécutive en terminant à la deuxième
place de prénationale derrière paris or
club
la question sur ce thème vaut-il mieux
monter ou gagné une coupe gagnée vous
gagnez beaucoup vous et nous
avec ça vous commencez vous êtes les
spécialistes en la poésie c'est un
niveau départemental qui ne rapporte que
rien ni financièrement ni sportive
membres désignés en gagner contre une
équipe qui a deux divisions en dessous
dont les meilleures équipes aussi ne
joue pas en l'occurrence versailles en
prénatal ans pour l'âge ou pas il ya
plein de clubs qui ne la joue pas aussi
donc bon après ça peut servir comme
match d'entraînement pourquoi pas des
choses comme ça mais mais bon je vais
vous dire que plaisir laissant
volontiers toute leur finale de coupe
gagné contre une montée en n3 qu'ils
essayent depuis une dizaine d'années ils
finissent depuis cinq six ans la
deuxième place la question si général
d'accor sera plus évident alors une
coupe
effectivement par exemple avec devenir
foot par exemple
bah oui mais pour un club de ligue 2 ou
de lilian humble ligue 1 il vaut mieux
gagner une coupe de france de belgique
de pardon qu'une montre avec une montée
venturin ligue 1 où tu vas prendre que
des 1 tu gagnes de l'argent c'est
important comme si on prenait le cas de
la coupe de france dans le football
toutes les équipes de on va dire de
ligue et changerait évidemment une place
de championnat mais monte h pour à la
coupe de france d'abord financièrement
c'est juste un jackpot
donc c'est très très très fortement
monnayer mais l'on parle de la coupe du
monde et il est bien entendu que c'était
la cause des yvelines clairement c'est
le niveau district c'est au niveau
départemental et puis la coupe on l'a
souvent dit c'est ça se joue à chaque
fois sur un match pour le championnat
clairement ça ne vaut on triche pas
c'est vraiment les allers retours c'est
plusieurs matchs on n'échange pas un
championnat contre une coupe
par contre on peut les mener de front sa
peut être
quelque chose qui peut être abordée
différemment surtout si on sait qu'on
monte pas par exemple
donc ça peut être des défis internes
mais on n'échange pas à ce niveau là
yann ça peut remobiliser un groupe c'est
que cette coupe
je pense à champ qu'ils ont été
démoralisés par set cet échec de la
montée on sait que c'est leur mobile
zain group
elle fera un petit peu un cadeau pour je
suis pas spécialiste de handball mais là
je pense que ce que nous a dit alexandre
ces voix là c'est pourri il serait qu'
il serait prêt à échanger nord xe coupe
de la ligue coupe des yvelines contre
une montée en n3 donc non c'est là je
pense qu'en plus ils ont joué contre une
équipe qui avait deux divisions
inférieures ça n'a vraiment refléter à
rien en rien le jeu qui peuvent qui
peuvent fournir
on est dimanche tous les week-ends voilà
ainsi buts de retard donc les oubliés de
10 de plus qu'une fille 1 19 buts tu
vois pas l'intérêt si vous passez quant
à l'état des pénalités quand tu débutes
par par odeur de moisi moi je pense que
ça peut être à sa part un effet positif
sur la samba prêt si un groupe vit bien
là coup de frein la coupe de france des
vignes pardon et qui va au bout du truc
c'était quand même une aventure sympa
vivre sur un sport co sa garde une
vitrine aussi pour clore à la vitrine
non moi je prends je parle presque plus
d'esprit vraiment de groupe
si le groupe n'est pas réussi à monter
que c'est traquer les joueurs qui
volontairement partir et derrière il ya
une aventure humaine finalement qu' elle
sait qu'une cousine est d'accord avec
toi mais mais je pense que ce sont les
appels se trouve ça peut créer un truc
quoi je trouve ce niveau basile sanist
pas d'accord il faut que moi j'ai
évidemment j'ai peu de vie peu d'avis
dessus là ça a permis à l'entraîneur de
plaisir de faire jouer un peu un peu les
jeunes de leur donner du temps de jeu
peut-être effectivement de la confiance
et de l'envié de rester au club la
saison prochaine donc je pense un peu
comme comme guillaume que ça permet déjà
de créer une dynamique avant avant l'été
pour pour la prochaine saison comme peut
l'être
les premiers tours de coupe de france
qui joue avant avant les vacances
maintenant ma petite question c'était
donc
versailles et d'autres clubs ne jouent
pas sept coups des vignes ne s'engage
pas pourquoi et pourquoi ne pas engager
le club et faire jouer par exemple
l'équipe réserve qui pourrait justement
ce qu'on fait voilà je vous la raconte
alors l'équipe réserve jours mais tu
préserve quai qui a le niveau
départemental donc il ya le niveau de la
coupe des yvelines qui est une coupe
département d'accord il ya un intérêt de
jouer des équipes non plus mais le plus
relevé quoi pouvoir
et puis si vous le cul de poule a de la
coupe davis et les dix premières équipes
alexandre voulez non mais on la joue ce
rôle là je vais pas là on la joue pas du
tout c'est l'équipe réserve puisque les
trouveras ton département donc c'est à
elle de jouer cette coupe moi je trouve
ça important dans la vie du club que
l'équipe rien ne prennent pas tous les
strates ne fait pas du tout les machins
donc voilà il ya une et qu'il ya une
coupe pour l'équipe 2 la quotidienne
coup pour l'équipe de france qui est une
coupe de france particulière en basque
de france régionale alors que les
régions jouent entre eux donc c'est on
devient la meilleure équipe régions de
france
c'est à dire qu'on les championnats
nationaux jouent la coupe de france
entre les championnats nationaux et les
championnats régionaux joue une coupe de
france entre championnats régionaux et
championnat départemental joue aussi une
coupe de france entre championnat
départemental
sauf qu'on n'engage qu'une seule équipe
par club donc nous on prend la place
pour le championnat de france régionale
entre guillemets et donc l'équipe 2 fait
la cnil des yvelines voilà départemental
de voile et la singine intéressant la
finalité se passe quand même avant les
pros avant la finale de coupe de france
des pros on va passer maintenant à notre
prochain thème c'est le j'aime j'aime
pas de base il rigolé
notre chroniqueur à basile regoli le
lebron james tube sport local nous
présente ces tops et les flops du
week-end à chaque émission on commence
par le premier j'aime il concerne le
handball jingle il concerne une entente
une belle initiative sur la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pour
développer le hand féminin
ils ont décidé les clubs de la
communauté d'agglo de se regrouper pour
les si je dis pas de bêtises sont les
moins de 17 moins de 18 féminines
donc ça concerne n'est donc l'initiative
vient de surtout de froid de philippe le
trancher entraîneur à montigny le
bretonneux qui a contacté les clubs
rêvent d'un entraîneur dé l'équipe une
de l'équipe
voilà qu'à contacter clubs avoisinants
donc voisin guillon voit la trappe
elancourt elancourt maurepas pour leur
proposer un projet s'est monté eu une
équipe compétitive avec les meilleures
joueuses qui évolueront donc tu auras
une équipe première qui évoluera au
niveau championnat de france moins de 18
ans l'équipe ii évoluera au niveau
régional et une équipe 3 au niveau
départemental donc c'est vraiment créer
un collectif féminin sur la communauté
d'agglomération pour permettre à ses
filles pas d'être dans une équipe qui
correspond à leur potentiel et pas
d'avoir deux trois éléments dans chaque
dans chaque club qui sont au dessus du
lot et qui s'ennuient un petit peu au
niveau où elle joue et on peut espérer
qu'à terme ça permette à ses meilleures
joueuses d'arriver en seniors et d'être
déjà compétitif si elle évolue ensuite
en n1 n2 et noir ont fait cette création
c'est que en fait montini avait jusqu'à
cette année et non plus une équipe moi
je te plains france tout seul ils ont
perdu leur place cette année et donc
c'était un et moyen de recréer cette
dynamique de chapeau aux enfants dans
les yvelines chez les filles parce qu'il
y en avait qu'une eau cristalline avec 0
j'avais d'ailleurs dommageable que
plaisir et saint cyr qui font partie de
l'agglo ont refusé bon pour diverses
raisons un plaisir je sais pas ce que ne
voulez pas investir sur les filles
voulaient investir que sur les garçons
mais bon au final les garçons les moins
de buts ne sont pas non plus qualifiés
prochaine donc il n'y aura plus
d'équipement du championnat de france
l'année prochaine dans dans l'est enfin
il aura une seule partie de l'entente de
houille ne verra pas deux donc voilà
c'est un peu dommage je pense que des
cas des initiatives pour pour les jeunes
il faut il faut sauter sur l'occasion et
débloqué un budget pour ce soit fille ou
garçon
on va voter et ton plus fort à plusieurs
oui ou non vers pour wii rouge pour nan
men tous d'accord bon alexandre on va
vous mettre en duel avec moustapha enfin
pardon jeu
moi j'arrive on semblait être d'accord
mais quand j'ai changé quand même gérer
un maire et un bémol inverse étant plus
fort alors alors non l'enfer est pavé
souvent de bonnes intentions c'est à
dire que le fait de dire on crée des
ententes ont créé des regroupements moi
ça me plaît toujours d'ailleurs on
pourrait l'imaginer dans le saint
quentinois bien des égards donc bien
d'autres domaines dans le foot par
exemple envoyer l'armée toutes les
équipes saint-quentinoise créé l'équipe
saint-quentinoise de football
c'est un débat qui rouvre là c'est le
serpent de mer où j'en avais parlé il ya
dix ans sauf que ou fait la paix il faut
une présidence c'est une présence
collective c'est une présidence
tournante c'est une pratique
techniquement c'est assez compliqué donc
du coup c'est que le meilleur gagne
c'est un peu comme ça que ça finit mais
j'aime bien l'idée clairement sauf que
techniquement j'ai un peu de mal à
comprendre comment ça peut se passer
parce que quand on voit les rivalités de
club mais qui sont pas malsain en
l'occurrence mais il ya des rivalités
deux clubs sur 2 encore une fois par
rapport au niveau par rapport à
l'entraînement par rapport au management
ça veut dire qu'on va avoir des gens qui
participent à un club dans certaines
catégories dans leur club et il y aurait
une entente sur certaines catégories
caisse quid d'avant quid d'après et et
comment commence à s'organiser sur ces
zus le bémol que j'apporte parce que
encore une fois je prends par les
marchés
avec dans leurs alliés durant deux ans
et c'est un échec info l'europe mais
puisque la paix noces c'est une entente
entre plusieurs heures entre plusieurs
clubs
5 puis 6 et il ya une première année et
qui a été très intéressante où on a fait
le meilleur résultat de des yvelines et
qu'elle avait fait en championnat de
france n'a jamais fait par contre la
deuxième année ça a été une catastrophe
et on s'est pas qualifié d'ailleurs dû
pour la prochaine pour la prochaine
édition du championnat de france
et parce que les clubs ne jouent pas
tous le jeu il ya des clubs qui ne
donnent pas leurs joueurs et
appartements ou des clubs ne jouent pas
le jeu et qui a pas une règle commune
ça ne peut pas fonctionner donc mais à
la mer s'il y a des ententes qui
fonctionne bien qui sont supportés pas
comme celle-là par le comité mais comme
celle du 95 cependant pas longtemps du
val d'oise qui vient de faire vice
champion de france des moins de 18 ans
deuxième meilleur club soit 96 donc vous
êtes enfin nous dire qu'il faut jouer le
jeu à fond
il faut que je me donne à fond pour ça
marche sinon jouent pas le jeu et au
sexe et on va vers l'a46 mme khatun donc
donc sa dépense après une réussite comme
ça peut être un gros test
louhans basket
avec élan et vit une basket qui est un
regroupement des meilleurs équipes de
jeu des meilleurs jeunes de poissy
maurepas et versailles le chesnay ses
gammes à s'éloigner poissy maurepas
versailles le chesnay et c'est pourtant
une totale réussite les a été champion
de france je crois en moi disent athées
la voilà exactement l'an dernier et vice
champion de france cette année donc
c'est des ententes entre deux clubs là
ce sont des ententes deux clubs mais je
suis rué sur des catégories jackson
savoura passé à votre deuxième gel
basile il concerne bac et isme jingle
cet avocat zyl oui un coup de chapeau 1
jeunes athlètes cadets de de versailles
spécialiste du 400 m haies
c'est un jeune qui s'était déjà révélé
l'an dernier en terminant à la quatrième
place au championnat de france en 163
seconde 63 60 on lui promettait une
belle saison 2016 et il est présent
rendez-vous il a réalisé 52 49 au
championnat d'île de france où il
remporte le championnat d'île de france
et ce chrono et est intéressant parce
que il lui permet d'être sélectionné en
équipe de france pour le championnat
d'europe qui aura lieu au mois de
juillet mais surtout quand on regarde
les bilans mondiaux il vient de rentrer
dans le top 10 mondial sur la discipline
donc ça sera un candidat crédible pour
une médaille aux championnats d'europe
ça c'est une surprise c'est une surprise
non on l'avait comme je dis on la veille
c'était vraiment révélé l'an dernier
lors de sa première année
terminant 4e 4e au championnat de france
mais il était que première année donc il
n'y confirme il a passé un cap
et voilà on est content de le voir à ce
niveau là viana une réaction par rapport
à cette performance est juste sur les
photos qu'on a vu on voit que je pense
qu'elles datent pas toutes de la même
période mais on voit que les dernières
la technique s'est largement amélioré et
donc bah il a dû il a dû travailler très
sérieusement et et puis les temps tu me
parles de passer d'une mine de plus
d'une minute à moins d'une minute vingt
proche de rennes sa part est de 60
secondes c'est lé 10e 54 bon d'accord
mais bon voilà il a dû il a dû bosser et
puis même gagné une seconde sur sur 1
400 quand on est quand on est deux
façons déjà au très haut niveau c'est
toujours c'est toujours énorme base il
vous le voyez gagné médaille gérard aux
joj au championnat du monde
salimata pression surtout que c'est
beaucoup trop tôt bon c'est un jeune
homme qui a fait que à peine 17 ans donc
c'est beaucoup de motos déjà si ramène
une médaille d'un championnat d'europe
qui a dès cet été
ça sera déjà très admirable ma ville on
va passer à votre troisième j'aime
il concerne un footballeur jingle
yannick mamie lon yannick mamie lon
exactement pour faire un petit à petit
un petit retour sur son parcours
rapidement yannick mille tonnes en 2013
c'est le meilleur buteur du championnat
d'excellence départementale à plaisir
voilà il termine la saison meilleur
buteur avec 22 ou 23 buts
il se fait remarquer les mureaux lui
propose d'intégrer
son égale leur équipe qui évolue en
division d'honneur il fait deux saisons
en dh donc le plus haut niveau régional
et il termine c'était l'an dernier en
2015 meilleur buteur une nouvelle fois
de la dh avec plus d'une vingtaine de
buts derrière tout s'enchaîne poissy le
contact il va voir si cette année en cfa
donc le quatrième échelon national
pareil il termine l'année meilleur
buteur 18 buts et elle avait là la belle
histoire continue avec amiens qui
remonte en ligue 2 cette année qui l'a
qu'il a contacté qu'il avait déjà
contacté au mercato hivernal mais il
avait refusé pour terminer la saison
avec la cie essayer de les faire monter
ça va marcher mais à miers venu lui a
proposé un contrat et il va il a signé
son premier contrat professionnel la
semaine dernière donc plutôt une belle
ascension pour onze garçons kiki bon tu
sûrement et un gène qui rêvait de
devenir footballeur professionnel et
mais voilà il ya encore trois ans quand
il évolue au niveau départemental je
pense qu'il est loin d'imaginer les
jeunes à laval 5 en avril
il avait ainsi je ne l'aï jamais passé
sur un centre de fin de formation
donc il faut qu'il faut là le temps que
ça mustapha 25 ans ce n'est pas trop
tard bon c'est bien sûr que c'est pas ça
par contre je vois là nous l'avait déjà
vu le jem de 90 je connais pas les
demandes ans évolue déjà dans des
sphères qu'on n'aborde pas mais on
attrape le jem de notre ami c'est un
j'aime que j'adore pour le coup c'est
vraiment des progressions comme cela
qu'on aime avoir plus que puisque
certaines des modèles paraissait way qui
paraissent évidentes
celle là c'est vraiment voilà je joue à
un niveau et je m'engage je prétends pas
par contre on ne voit gens qu'elle était
moins qu'ils prétendent qu'ils
prétendaient au final on les voit
revenir ce garçon ne prétend pas ils
montrent ils partent pas au mercato
d'hiver parce qu'il veut finir sa saison
oui les frêles épaules sur vos parts
dont il a la tête sur les épaules a
clairement refusé à 25 ans faut bref osé
quand même pose moi mais c'est son nom
est la preuve
la preuve c'est qu'il y revient la
tentation est grande la tentation est
grande de partir rapidement de prendre
tout de suite et maintenant moi je
trouve cette histoire est assez assez
assez assez simple prochaine retraite -
suivre l'année prochaine
basile vous avez également un j'aime pas
il concerne le baseball jingle et le
calendrier des couverts de mentir aux
taux n'est pas le déséquilibre mal de
les équipes de ms bol de 2e division de
baseball faut savoir que le calendrier
cette année propose une phase régulière
qui s'étend de avril jusqu'à fin juin
donc il va se terminer ce week-end les
cougars de vrais terrains même début
juillet début juillet juillet à la la
deuxième place de leurs de leur
championnat et sont donc qualifiés pour
les pour les play-offs et les play-offs
ils ont lieu au mois de septembre à
partir de mi-septembre mulot deuxième
week-end de septembre ou en bus deux
mois de vacances
ils ont deux mois de vacances
préparation ils sont à leur meilleur
niveau ils ont fait une grosse
préparation une grosse préparer dit qu
il joue des matches tous les week-ends
et va y avoir une pause de deux mois et
il faudra jouer alors c'est pas
totalement 2
de leur faute tout simplement c'est
parce que dans cette deuxième division
il ya l'équipe fédérale qui en fait
l'équipe du pôle espoir de toulouse où
il ya les meilleurs jeunes qui sont qui
sont formés et qu'on a un championnat
d'europe qui ont un championnat d'europe
juniors au mois de juillet donc on peut
pas jouer les play-offs avec une équipe
qualifiée qui n'est pas du tout présente
donc on est obligé de jouer les
play-offs après ces championnats
vous souhaitez donc je vais avoir bobo
falloir attendre deux mois avant de dire
oui il faut repenser le championnat
c'est ridicule c'est ridicule c'est
ridicule parce qu'en plus les gamins qui
partait aux europe ils votent à donf à
fond à la rentrée quoi ils vont
s'arrêter
enfin c'est ridicule tu fais comment
s'échapper d'un mois avant deux ans fin
février même si les ferries est
compliqué le baseball mais nous fasse
par l'extérieur donc il faut qu'ils
s'adaptent savate en pensez quoi de ce
mois trois mois de trois mois de
préparation pour pour un pour un
championnat qui va se dérouler au mois
d'octobre
donc ça me choque pas du tout maintenant
c'est vrai que c'est non mais voilà là
ce serait de moi maintenant c'est des
jeunes sacrifiés des vacances d'été pour
passer son temps sur sur les terrains
pour pour participer aux playoffs
quatre matches quatre matches de payer
je sais pas ce que ça peut apporter
porté derrière je suis pas d'accord ils
sont atteints je suis pas sûr que tout
le monde soit prêt à le faire cette
année moi je le fais je le fais pas tous
les ans en effet mais ça dit je le fais
pour préparer les championnats du monde
mais voilà c'est pas et peel est calme
c'est un c'est l'individuel c'est pas
une équipe c'est bien du mal à jouer et
là c'est pas et là c'est pas gagné donc
c'est vrai que là il est quand même un
gros gros problème au niveau de
l'organisation et donc de
une bonne tête pensante de nos dans nos
fédérations respectives
rapidement sa mue au spectacle ce
calendrier au spectacle je ne pense pas
parce qu'il y aura du spectacle au mois
de septembre je pense que les joueurs
qui joueront ces play-offs ont envie de
ça il ya pas de 87 ans le foot américain
les mercatos est plutôt sur l'hiver n'a
pas son univers maintenant on peut
imaginer qu'ils osent en descendant
genre d'imitation professionnels qui
doivent partout des ménages cet été qui
pourront peut-être pas le meilleur il ya
entraîné ou des étudiants 70 ans les
wallabies ont un véritable casse tête
pour la préparer correctement ces
play-offs après le j'aime j'aime pas de
zazie regoli on passe à notre rubrique
débats 30 ans ça se fête les templiers
en cours ont passé le cap de la
trentaine au complexe sportif europe
avec une grande manifestation des petits
matchs des démonstrations aux
cheerleaders une exposition photos
retraçant l'histoire du club était
organisée ce samedi en présence du staff
des joueurs et des anciens séquence
émotion pour les templiers on les écoute
qu'est ce que çà mau sur wii mais
effectivement que j'ai pris ton temps
puisque j'étais là au premier
entraînement des cormo'rock sont devenus
par la suite layton les templiers
donc voilà ça nous rajeunit pas mais
c'est une très belle fête aujourd'hui
voilà on retrouve les anciens et à tout
le monde a pris trente ans il n'y a pas
que moi un plaisir de faire partie de
cette famille et une envie de relève
envie de prendre le relais et de
produits sexy des anneaux coach plein de
souvenirs plein plein d'amitié plein de
voyage et voir des gens que j'ai pas
revu depuis
20 25 voire 30 ans tout début et qui
vont arriver les uns après les autres au
fil de la journée les templiers font
partie des meilleures équipes de france
qu'ils ont participé à des matchs de
coupe d'europe le nombre de licenciés
est passé de 45 adhérents à 270
adhérents en trente ans le club est tout
de même redescendu en deuxième division
cette saison
le bilan est il positif messieurs vous
votez oui ou non quelques secondes de
réflexion pour alexandre taillefer qui
est toujours partagée on va faire un
petit duel alexandre contre bâle et vous
yann vous est très sympa c'est un mot
que je voudrais c'est de partager si
c'est vrai que c'est une belle
progression et
lai partir du 45 qui est monté à cinq
fois plus en laissant une trentaine
d'années sur un sport qui est quand même
pas non plus un sport majeur en france
quand même donc il faut donc qu'ils ont
ils ont ils font un travail local qui de
recrutement local qui doit être
important maintenant maintenant c'est
dommage que voilà cette année l'équipe
une n'ai pas réussi à
à conserver sa place parmi l'élite quoi
c'est vraiment c'est sur ces trente ans
leur est il positif
oui ou non après voilà est-ce que y est
ce qu'ils ont réussi déjà remporté un
titre d'un titre de champion voilà donc
le nom est-ce qu'ils ont budget pour
pouvoir le faire parce que c'est pareil
dans ses rangs fait beaucoup de finale
mais jamais ils n'ont remporté deux
titres d'accord mais bon ça veut dire
qu'ils ça veut dire qui se bagarrent
donc là voilà ça peut être un faux pas
cette année qui va vite être qui va leur
permettre de repartir pour une pour une
nouvelle pour une sur une nouvelle
dynamique
en espérant qu'ils fassent une descente
remontée dans l'élite directement
l'année prochaine moi je pense qu'il
faudra vraiment il manque une stat
savoir les autres clubs combien de
licenciés dont lui en plus sûr content
parce que 30 ans à fait à même pas dix
licenciés et à calculer
de plus par action d'éclat de la
création des clubs donc c'est pas tant
que ça après on peut dire on s'est perdu
koné il aurait pu en perdre n'ont pas
perdu mais bon je pense qu'il faut
mettre un bémol parce que quand même le
foot us en france il se développe petit
à petit on les adopte la pub non mais
par blague à part c'est ça développe
comme un peu donc c'est logique j'ai
envie de dire que c'est de plus en plus
de licenciés de façon il ya plus en plus
de français donc il ya forcément plus en
plus de licenciés dans dans beaucoup de
sports
donc voilà j'ai dis pas que c'est tous
les sports comme ça mais on a une
tendance où il ya plus de français donc
les licenciés devrait augmenter dans à
peu près tous les sports mais bon trente
ans moi ça me paraît pas une
augmentation fulgurante
ça fait même pas 10 par an et en plus
derrière et l'art des centres en d2 mais
on peut dire qu'ils ont eu leur heure de
gloire ont joué des coupes d'europe des
finales de championnat de france et donc
voilà j'espère surtout que un club qui
était l'initiateur à la base ne va pas
s'écrouler et puis on marquerait
entendent parler comme ça a déjà été le
cas avec d'autres d'autres sports et
d'autres clubs surtout sa pensée ce que
je voulais dire sur la france il a dit
hey c'est à dire que ils étaient les
pionniers à 30 ans je disais que les ont
rattrapés en termes de niveau de
compétence et a donc peut-être que enfin
j'espère pour eux que c'est pas là c'est
pas la fin d'un sauna d'un style sexy
comme des clubs de top 14 de ligue 1 et
c'est qu'ils m'ont donnée arriver enfin
voilà c'est comme ça tous les ans rugby
était inquiet pour le montant oui ils
sont rattrapés aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
sont la masse il arrive que les titres
j'espère que pour eux ce sera pas le
annonciateur d'une mauvaise période pour
ça que ce soit d'après as peur moi je
disais que c'était que c'était positif
donc je continue à le penser mais c'est
vrai que comme dans tous les sports on a
connu une équipe de trappes par exemple
pour prendre un exemple que je connais
bien
80 ans dans les années 70 c'était le
club phare de la région
ça se baladait en dh et la difficulté
pour un club souvent c'est de gérer la
croissance et la croissance elle se fait
par rapport aux autres
effectivement le football à trappes à
l'époque on était les seuls au monde
depuis toutes les communes en leur
équipe
la rivalité augmente le niveau augmente
on voit même en coupe d'europe puisque
on a des équipes comme l'islande etc qui
rivalise avec très haut dès 13 ans
équipe donc le niveau monte pour tout le
monde donc c'est vrai que c'est toujours
relatif il faut voir quelle est la
progression nationale du nombre
d'adhérents mais ça reste un bilan très
positif en ce sens où ils ont su prendre
la main tout de suite et c'est la
gestion de la croissance qui est
compliqué donc ils sont probablement à
un tournant il faut qu'ils sachent faire
entre l'e-mail voilà une autocritique et
pour repartir après ça nécessite aussi
des financements il y en a parlé de cela
donc ces voix là c'est à m à mettre
boutabout à la fois le financement les
engagements et puis surtout voilà on
n'est pas tout seul dans ce sport mais
bilan positif quand même au bout de 30
ans on en parle ils ont la notoriété
ils ont maintenant ils peuvent encore
capitaliser sur leur monde donc il ya
encore du il ya des choses à faire
positif ouais je pense mais c'est
positif bien sûr basile le mal à part
bravo réussir à durer dans le temps et
dans une preuve de réussite et on parle
beaucoup de l'équipe fanion qui est
certes descendu mais ils ont fait un
gros travail au niveau de la formation
ils ont les alignements des équipes dans
toutes les catégories de jeunes et donc
ça c'est également une belle une belle
ray une belle réussite je pense pour les
u16 notamment qui a été recréé cette
année voilà exactement la section et 16
une équipe une équipe b aussi en seniors
donc il ya du monde et je pense que le
club va encore durer faire prévues
pendant quelques années
c'est la fin de ce débat on va parler à
m maintenant du coup de gueule darlot le
week
c'est une tradition dans cette émission
notre chroniqueur à naulleau goic alias
le grincheux yvelines au a poussé un
coup de gueule sur le sport dans le
département aujourd'hui arnaud qui est
toujours très remonté contre le monde du
sport va nous parler de l'engouement
dans les yvelines pour l'euro on voit sa
parole arlon merci michael mon coup de
gueule du jour concerne l'euro
versailles et les irlandais les
irlandais qui donc ont posé leur camp de
base à versailles dans la préfecture
évinoise
il ya eu un entraînement ouvert au
public qui avait attiré beaucoup de
monde notamment beaucoup de jeunes des
écoles et des écoles de foot des
environs mais c'est tout donc de mon
point de vue versailles est un peu passé
à côté
on a vu des images des irlandais dans
toute la france chante et ça a été le
des gros buzz de leurs hauts et bas à
versailles et on n'a pas profité
puisqu'elle à versailles avait pas d il
n'y avait pas de l'irlandais il n'était
pas là pourtant les infrastructures
notamment en transport qui aurait permis
de les faire venir au moins quelques
journées à versailles puisqu'ils étaient
pour la plupart à paris
on aurait pu installer pourquoi pas pour
les faire rester des écrans géants pour
diffuser leur match vraiment faire vivre
la ville autour de cet euro et l'irlande
puisque puisqu'il était à
je pense que versailles s'est passé à
côté voilà c'est un peu dommage c'est
mon avis êtes vous d'accord avec arnaud
le goïc ya un manque d'engouement à
versailles dans les yvelines pour leur
beauté oui ou non mais qu'est ce que tu
vois un petit duel entre guillaume et
moustapha guèye mon cancer allez-y
guillaume particulier ils sortent pas le
week-end ou comment ça se passe pour
fouiller le premier week-end de la coupe
d'europe un des coups les anglais sont
arrivés vers ça a été plein élan d tous
les bars la place du marché la place du
château farlow pareil c'est que tu as
tous les bars étaient pleins d'irlandais
ont fait l'ouverture de 14 heures à 12
heures du matin les trois jours donc il
était partout il y en avait partout il y
avait des télé irlandaise était là il y
avait voilà donc il y en a partout
maintenant c'est vrai que ça s'est un
peu détendue parce que les hollandais
bouge aussi un petit peu je vois là et
que vous me donnez balle et ça coûte
cher de boire des boissons des bugs et
après cotis par d'écran avec des crocs
joël abbey l'alcool est dangereux pour
la survie par le rappel des déboires des
boissons soft en lieu sûr après quand
ils pas des courts extérieurs c'est
interdit donc c'est tout c'est interdit
c'est la préfecture france et un arrêté
préfectoral même nationale je pense
qu'un interdit si c'est pas une phase de
tapas le roi donc c'est tout on n'a pas
de la vie peut rien faire mais moustapha
fut finalement vous pouvez être d'accord
parce que ouais on est d'accord parce
que c'est de ça dont il parle justement
s'il n'y a pas eu
l'organisation pour faire en sorte que
ça soit d'autant plus le fait il ya eu
des bars occupée par les errements
déchets partout même l'équipe d'irlande
qui allons absolument mois qu'il ya eu
c'est convivial en également à
versailles et de résider dans ce qu'il
dit ce que vous dites tous les deux
c'est que sporadiquement il ya eu voilà
il ya eu débat ouvert aux tailles mais
clairement il a l'air de c'est ce que je
ressemble ce que je comprends et en plus
il ya un argument compte pour ça c'est
qu'on a reçu ici je crois pour avoir vu
l'émission le responsable des sports de
la ville de versailles
jean-marc fans elle était venue qui
était bien en place l'émissaire spécial
euro 2016 et on a bien compris que
c'était exactement propos que j'avais en
début d'émission c'est que ça l'euro a
vraiment eu du mal sur l'aspect
sécuritaire et versailles en particulier
a fermé donc les fans zone n'était pas
question
il ya des tas le rassemblement qui était
prévu qu'ils ont été annulés donc la
ville de versailles a priori et est ce
que ces taux étaient plutôt réservés
sfr la sphère du vous n'êtes pas les
anglais winamax fr mais c'est bien mais
c'est que sur les fans zone solide sur
les coins vous pouvez imaginer des
rassemblements on les a pas vus me au
club de foot de certains clients de foot
d'appâter moteur nous c'est en 2007 que
versailles était moteur c'est sale
affaire c'est que globalement on n'a
rien vu du côté du club de foot de
versailles qui aurait pu être totalement
l'initiative parce que finalement un
plan fin versailles
le club de foot avait quand même des
références
la dh les joueurs la colline voilà je
pense qu'il a raison quand même sarr qui
n'a pas eu grand chose sur la ville sans
avoir jeté la pierre parce qu'ils
étaient vraiment dans un raisonnement
sécuritaire comme on a pu le dire pour
toutes les équipes en france en général
et finalement gagnent
qui a raison entre most après rio ils
sont d'accord tous les deux il ya le
plus raison c'est vrai que en effet on
est à versailles et on voit pas grand
chose on va pas grand chose maintenant
on n'a pas de match qu'ils sont on n'a
pas de manny pacman se retransmis donc
donc voilà c'est pas grave quoi je veux
dire mais comme le stade d'entraînement
il est rempli quand même les écoles ont
fait saliver en fait il est vrai le
musée reçoit parce que je sens bien
qu'il avait rappelé belgique a lancé
comme ça veut dire c'est pas le choix de
versa c'est ce que j'attends c'est que
d'être un ces femmes ces neuf faits un
sa responsabilité face à la
responsabilité
non mais bon c'est un moment mais je
veux dire c'est pas que lui facile et à
l'état français aussi abandonné mais
c'est normal on n'est pas dans une vie
période là on n'est pas dans une période
classique j'ai envie de dire je gagne
dans une période michael qu'on s'entend
bien c'est pas une faute
quand une foule ni de versailles de
l'état français c'est juste que d'après
coach depuis le début de l'euro en
parler c'est à cristalliser sa
cristallerie la crise mais tout n'est
donc il y en a qu'on fait le choix des
fans zones y en a qui l'ont pas fait
versa il l'a dit publiquement et
d'avenir on est plutôt partisan de
quelque chose de classe à checker séance
à qu'il a raison mais ça veut pas dire
que de vanessa hié ou tort d'avoir entre
guillemets parce que je sais bien que tu
es fan zone très grand dans les grandes
villes classées 500c n'existe pas donc
ses interventions il ya une petite
willow aujourd'hui tant que dong il ya
une toute petite fan zone a menti une
retenue pendant une semaine ils ont créé
une espèce de phase ii fan zone avec
quatre à cinq matchs retransmis moi vous
voilà ils ont attiré à peu près 400 à
500 personnes après versailles est quand
même plus médiatisé et plus facile
d'accès pratique d'accès pour
quant au président un mini des excuses à
une boum m a poussé à versailles comme
moody's à six jeunes est le berceau des
deux pilotes est arrivé concernant le
tabac de saint alexandre son protégé
versailles par rapport à la roja au
mondial c'est tout à fait normal s'il ya
bien une vie qui va pas faire de femmes
zone parce qu'elle n'a pas les moyens de
paris c'est bien versailles
parce que derrière paris tout le monde
connaît versa et dans le monde entier
donc
donc si tout à fait normal qu'avec ses
moyens ils vont pas tenter surtout que a
pas si loin que ça il ya des fans zone à
paris donc les jours en plus on va
fermer plus un truc à dire non plus vous
avez des présidents au palais famille
mais vous avez vous avez vu le champ de
mars
l'état de la pelouse du champ de mars ya
pas très longtemps ils ont remplacés par
des copeaux parce que c était un champ
de boue ses prestations ça sera le mois
de la faillite variés c'est la patate
émission merci nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve le jeudi à 7 juillet pour le
dernier numéro de la saison de six ans
par les sports n'oubliez pas que vous
pouvez regarder cette émission à nouveau
sur notre site internet et sur youtube
très belle soirée sur tv fil 78
mais l'heure exacte